address the question about middle of supplements and advocated the clear multiband.
I found that there's also a clear multiband plus on the store.
Okay, so the difference between clear multiband and clear multiband plus is that clear multiband plus
has a few other things in it. And one of the things that clear multiband plus has in it,
that clear multiband does not is iodine. Now there's a lot of controversy about iodine. So
if a person has hypothyroidism, so they have to give low thyroid, it's classified as either primary
hypothyroidism, meaning that they have low thyroid production, but they do not have an autoimmune
thyroid called Hashimoto's. So if you have antibodies to thyroglobulin or TPO antibodies
that are elevated, then you have Hashimoto's or Graves if you have hyperthyroid.
So those people in this thyroid category, anybody with hyperthyroid, Graves or Hashimoto's
should not take iodine. Now we know again, that's controversial because almost every alternative
doctor and many, many mainstream doctors will tell people to take iodine for their thyroid.
However, study after study after study has come out and people have not read those studies.
And if you want to go into detail about iodine and thyroid, go to the courses and go to
the autoimmune course and look at, I think it's the module eight that's all on the thyroid
and I go into depth so on once you look at that yourself. So I am recommending that you do clear
multi-mid not the clear multi-mid course.